welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Maryland Wilkes your host and our guest
is Dean Karlan a professor of economics
at Yale University professor Carlin has
been called one of the most creative and
prolific young economists in the world
his research lies at the intersection of
two of the hottest areas in the field
behavioral economics and development
microfinance with 3.4 million in funding
he just received from Citi foundation
professor Carlin and the organization he
founded innovations for poverty action
will conduct research on strategies to
improve the financial capability of low
and moderate income individuals across
the world this funding bills on a 7.3
million dollar grant he received from
the Bill and Melinda Gates Foundation to
study innovations in savings products
and payment channels for poor households
worldwide professor Carlin also has a
new book out that he wrote with Jacob
Appel entitled more than good intentions
improving the ways the world's poor
borrow save learn and stay healthy today
we talked with him about ways to end
global poverty
welcome professor Carlin thanks thanks
for having me
this is your second visit here with us
and so much has happened in the past
year the past five years since you've
been on you've received quite a bit of
research money and you have that at your
disposal to do some work so let's begin
by talking about the two grants you
received and what you're doing with the
money
sure well actually I don't use most of
the money they think the most exciting
thing is that we are seeing a lot of
other researchers interested in these
topics about how to use behavioral
economics in particular but the topics
go wider than just behavioral economics
but how to use economic analysis and
experiments in particular to
test out different ideas about how
people manage their cash how they manage
finances how they make decisions to
borrow and save and how to design better
products that will help people achieve
their goals better and so with both of
the both of these grants we have
actually a pot of money that we open up
competitively to researchers around the
world to propose ideas and some of it
has already been doled out through the
Gates Foundation and the City Foundation
grant we're now getting started as well
to to allocate it to good proposals that
come forward and so what some of it does
actually go to also fund some of the
research that that I'm doing but the
majority of it is actually to to give
out to other researchers interested in
these topics okay I do want to come back
to that and ask you what are some of
those specific things that have that
have produced but before we do that I
want to throw a quote out here that I
found in your book it says in your book
you write that we've thrown billions
down a sinkhole over the past 50 years
and accomplished almost nothing in
America alone individual donors
contribute over 200 billion to charity
annually and that's three times as much
as corporations foundations and bequests
combined I of course was shocked to read
that and I'm wondering why has that
money not made a difference and and what
what are we doing wrong basically so the
context in which I mean that is I
wouldn't say that the money has not made
a difference the problem is we don't
know if it's made a difference and so
yeah I don't learn from what we've done
in the past and that's the sense in
which it's been thrown out a sinkhole
with just a tiny sliver of that had gone
to understanding what's really working
and what's not then we can allocate each
each year can grow and grow in terms of
how much of our how much of the
donations are able to go towards things
that have really strong evidence behind
it and so it's always going to be a you
know a spectrum right and it's not to
say that every single dollar should only
go towards things which have strong
evidence behind them we we need to fund
innovation we need to fund
experimentation and and creative ideas
that are too early to have strong
evidence behind them and
need to fund that type of work do so
there's a there's a fair amount of
things that go into that space but the
problem over the years has been that we
just we see things get funded for
political reasons and because they sound
good basically when we look at the
individual donor money who made the best
appeal for the marketing approaches and
that's a shame and so the way we can do
much better is both by educating donors
about about what types of ideas have
strong evidence behind them and what do
not educating donors about which types
of organizations are learning
organizations or organizations which
really commit themselves to testing
their core principles and finding out
just what I do work and if not how do
can we shift into something that works
better I much prefer to support an
organization with my if I'm gonna
support my with my own money an
organization that has done things that
didn't actually prove to work but they
documented it and they showed this
didn't work and they moved on right
that's huge the leverage from that for
the world to learn from that is much
bigger and so I personally would further
support organizations even if everything
doesn't come out roses as long as
they're carefully documented to an
organization that does something which
sounds good what doesn't have strong
evidence behind them sure let's talk
about some of those researchers that you
did give funding to what are some of the
projects that are going on out in the
world and and what are you finding so
one of the the well a lot of the results
are not in from any of the stuff we find
it's been two recent and the allocated
the money to the to the actual projects
our first allocation of money was six
months ago I believe okay so what I can
speak to as broadly but some of the
research that went into how we chose
which project to fund and greater than
that so for instance in the space of
microfinance you for the longest time
microfinance has been defined almost
anonymously as microcredit and the you
know there's two problems with that one
is that microfinance the word finance
means a lot more than credit it also
means savings and it means insurance and
and one could also often include things
like financial education into into this
kind of large rubric but yet the
emphasis a lot of the organizations over
the years has been on
credit side and one of the things that
has happened is in the in the rigorous
evaluations that randomised trials that
have been done on microcredit it's not
the case that the the promise of
microcredit has come true right the
promise being to like lift millions of
people out of poverty it is the case
that some important positive benefits
were found so on average things were
looking good it was looking like a good
program but not one that lives up to its
its its promises that have been made for
years and and furthermore it was also
clear that it wasn't so that the donor
money wasn't so clear that it was needed
the for profits were coming in and
having this doing the same thing as the
nonprofit's why do you you know so that
the nonprofit served their role thirty
years ago in kind of that innovation
phase figuring out how to do this and
this is actually a good model in general
for the world like subsidize the
innovation phase see that something can
be done but then find out that it
actually is sustainable to do as a
for-profit enterprise let the investor
money come in and then take it to scale
now so the so the first problem in that
big phase was the lack of attention to
the savings and to insurance and those
are now in that similar spot that I
think credit was 20 or 30 years ago in a
sense that was now innovating figuring
out how to do this seeing that there can
be really big benefits from savings and
in insurance that a lot of times that
people were borrowing they were
borrowing because they didn't have a
good savings option or a good insurance
option and that's actually what they
would prefer and that's actually the
better fit for what their their needs
were and we are seeing in the rigorous
evidence much bigger impacts from the
savings and insurance interventions than
we do from the credit interventions okay
the second big problem with the term
microcredit is the way it's so easy to
flip it around and make it sound bad by
just calling it micro debt and it's one
of the one of those simple cases where
language tells us a lot about the
viewpoints - someone has when I get a
phone call from a journalist who asks me
questions about micro debt I immediately
know that this is a journalist who was
trying to write a story that's comes out
badly for micro credit
because they're calling it that I know
that yeah we are in credit right very
simple point but you really tell a lot
we're showing which people use and the
problem is that the critics of
microcredit the ones who call it micro
dad had just as bad evidence as the
proponents just simple before after
stories of people who had loans and then
bad things happen to them and it's the
same thing as the the proponents of
microcredit who pointed to people who
had loans and good things happen to them
we don't know what would have happened
had either of them not gotten access to
loans and this is what the randomized
trials have done for us this helped us
understand what would have happened had
people not gotten access to loans did
things get better or worse and we're
using that same approach when we do our
evaluations of savings and insurance
where we are finding much systematically
much bigger impacts what parts of the
world are you working in so personally I
don't I don't I have some areas where I
do more work than others but we're very
much more idea focused than region focus
in the way from tackle problems so I do
a lot of work in ghana uganda
philippines i used to do a lot of work
in peru unless so now so we're fairly
spread out
organizationally innovations for poverty
action is spread out in 45 countries
with big presence in 14 countries and i
use you know IPA innovations about
reaction over to its IPA is the the
field arm that coordinates all of the
research that I do okay I'm looking for
a success story if you will I mean can
you cite any particular particular
project that you know of that is
succeeding and why it's succeeding so
within the space of microfinance the
there's three that we we often will
point to two that are on the saving side
and one on insurance so one that I'm
particularly excited about is work that
I've done with Chris huge we here at
Yale and Robert acai and Isaac acai at
the University of Ghana and here we set
up a study in in northern Ghana where
there was a lot of under investments in
agriculture specifically fertilizer very
would seem to be clear evidence that
there's returns to be had from investing
more money in fertilizer but yet we see
fertilizer use lower than we think it's
should be from the agronomy studies that
are done and so we wanted if I know why
aren't why aren't people investing and
there are two leading hypotheses because
everybody knows about fertilizer so you
know one hypothesis that could be put
for use they don't know about the
returns but it seems like if you ask
people do you know that fertilizer can
make you more money most people say yes
so that didn't seem to be from a
diagnostic process what the issue was
the things people talk about is I don't
have the money and the other thing they
talk about is I don't want to put money
into it it's too risky yeah I'm afraid
that if I take all my money and put it
into my farm and then there's not that
good rain I lose everything right so I
need to I don't want to put it in
because I'm afraid of the risk so we
tested out both of those stories
simultaneously by taking some farmers
and then randomly assigning them to one
of four groups one group we gave them
money we didn't give them alone we
didn't want to see whether they were
willing to take out the loan there's a
lot of issues that then you'd have to
ask about why they're willing or not
willing we just wanted to give them
money just find out whether if we
relaxed the I don't have money
explanation by giving them money would
they then put money in the in the farm
right with another group where we gave
them free rainfall insurance and the
idea here is let's take away that risk
so we just tell them look if rainfall is
really bad we're gonna give you money we
don't give them any money upfront right
so there's no extra relaxation of their
of their problem of I don't have money
right all we do is we say to them if
there's bad rainfall we'll cover your
losses there's a third group that got
both because maybe even if they have
money they're not willing to put it in
because of the risk so let's do a third
group where we both give the money and
the rainfall insurance and then a fourth
group they got nothing that's the
control group and we did this over three
years different the experiment got a
little more complicated in the second
and third year but the basic result was
really striking that the insurance was
really what was driving things so even
in the rainfall insurance only group we
gave them no money investment in the
farm went up more fertilizer use more
hiring of labor to work the farm and
more acres cultivated now if we gave the
money to we also did see some
investments but now
as many but it's really striking to us
how much more investment took place
after just removing the risk and not
giving money it says that you know it's
not to say that they weren't liquidity
constrains and didn't and didn't have to
struggle to come up with the money but
it does say when you took away the risk
they figured out how to come up with
money to invest more in the fire and
that's a very striking story that tells
us that we need to figure out better how
to mitigate risk right for the poor
because it is holding back growth
because investment leads to growth and
leaves all sorts of other good things
and if risk is the underlying problem
that's something we need to tackle
better so the question of the day do you
think global poverty can ever be ended
no no no that's - you know that's the
type of rhetoric that you hear a lot I
always cringe when I've had many
situations where I'm giving talks and
someone proposes the title of solving
global poverty this book that I just
wrote released recently you know that
wasn't initially in the in the subtitle
and we had to kind of negotiate that out
like these things can make big
differences and it's really striking
sometimes how big a difference one can
make with it were the small
interventions but ending global poverty
is setting yourself up for failure right
that's just a little bit too ambitious I
mean look at America we have poverty
here - right even if our best of dreams
is to get some of the countries that
we're working in to look like America
when it comes to economic well-being we
still have poverty here right so you
know it's not we're always going to have
problems and the only question is how
can we improve from where we are now
okay great what are your plans moving
forward so moving forward there is I
think there's a lot more work that we
need to do and how to implement some of
these ideas so I'm particularly excited
by the efforts to scale up some of these
solutions take rainfall insurance so we
have this this study was on you know
very carefully done now the question is
how do you market this on a larger scale
to get people to buy rainfall insurance
right
same thing on savings we've seen really
strong evidence from commitment savings
accounts
and from using text messages to remind
people to save from from three different
studies with just just that sending
people simple text messages but now
there's a whole world of questions about
how to actually implement this on a
larger scale and to do it in a
cost-effective way
and I think that's a lot of the the
tension we see is that a lot of the
studies are about ideas and so we
learned that an idea works but then the
next question we have to ask is how do
you implement this on a large scale and
how do you get the cost to be down and
we can't forget that the I the the the
prize at the end of the day is not just
validating an idea but validating idea
that can work I had large-scale I would
imagine communication would be one of
the obstacles that needed to be overcome
in terms of the implementation of a good
idea
yeah and that's where each all of those
people it's there's communication in
terms of selling things and there's
communication also to organizations and
so and there's both levels that need to
be worked out so you know take take the
rainfall insurance to continue with this
example how do you actually market that
what's the right marketing approach
we've seen studies that have financial
education given prior to to farmers that
makes a big difference in their
willingness to purchase rainfall
insurance I've done studies and so
that's really encouraging and it makes
sense but we also see that lots of other
things can really affect what people buy
that don't don't fit into our world of
what we want to be influencing things I
did a study on on credit in South Africa
and it turned out that showing pictures
are pretty women to to potential
borrowers was just as effective at
getting them to borrow was dropping
their interest rate by a third Wow right
so you know yeah sex sells we know this
from lots of marketing although that's
why that's why we see it all the time in
advertising but that doesn't fit so well
with our way of thinking about how to
deliver poverty programs no one ever
talks about using sex to sell to sell
your services as an NGO how did you
actually think of to come up with
something like that very simply we were
we were doing a study that we needed to
send out some direct marketing to people
to get them
where we wanted to see how their
behavior change depending on what
interest rate they were paying and we
needed a lot of people to come in so we
sat down with the marketing material
from the bank and just thought about how
one could improve it mm-hm and we were
just brainstorming from different ideas
from behavioral economics and psychology
and economics uh-huh about how to make
this the best marketing thing ever
and we realized how little we actually
knew about which ones of these ideas
which have lots of laboratory evidence
behind them out there in the real world
were really going to play out and a lot
of marketing people do this for a living
but they don't share the data with us
dorky academics all the time so we don't
have that much actual real data about
how people respond to these things and
so that was you know all of a sudden
what became really just brainstorming
for how to improve the marketing we
realized was actually interesting to
test in its own right and to compare to
the interest rate so that we had some
relative sense of not just does it
matter but we can actually quantify how
much it matter is relative to the thing
that we economists stick in all our
models which is price and so that was
how that came to be well thank you very
much for being here with us today and
sharing some of your work it's very
fascinating thanks for having me okay
for more information about Professor
Carlin and his research please visit our
website at Yale edu / Macmillan report
be sure to join us again for another
episode of the Macmillan report made
possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Center for
International and area studies at Yale
you